okay four people joining the livestream
we haven't had one of these for a little
while we've been busy finishing version
12 and I'm happy to say that version 12
should be ready to go next week and
least my role in it is pretty much done
well no it isn't I've still gotta write
all kinds of blogs and things huh okay
in any case um we are talking about
language completeness and consistency
and we have an agenda of items here so
let's get going
packed array Q and the function
repository shouldn't put things which
are documented in to the function
repository right so that that does sound
crazy when you put it that way it sounds
crazy doesn't it so if I look at packed
array Q it direct hits
yeah that's arguably crazy so I think we
need to discuss what we want to do with
this stuff in the future I mean whether
we want to have you know I would say
that the developer and experimental
contexts have not been a wild success I
mean they're what's in the developer
context right now if I asked for that
there are many more things that are
actually documented partly because
people just assume that they could put
whatever they want in it and partly
because it's so damn hard to write
developer context documentation that
most people don't bother even if they
what's involved in doing it the story
tools supported or not well you need to
write you need to reset your
documentation directory from the from
system to the packages so as we get this
more lightweight packet documentation
stuff that should get fixed but I agree
that that's completely crazy yes so okay
so the question is what are we doing
with all these things because some of
them I mean
you know how many of them are even
documented we know there there's a guide
page which lists most of the documented
ones hopefully all of them okay right
there at the bottom there's a
development link developer utilities
package that is a pathetic list relative
to a complete list here yes okay let's
have a quick look so how's the function
repository team looked at these does
anybody know
Sushma do you know so functional
positive team did add the document did
once to the function of posit or e nada
mmm undocumented ones okay which is
possibly the opposite of what should
have happened maybe maybe okay look this
is pretty pathetic what we have here I
mean the good news is okay let's let's
let's look at the picture here I mean
these are somewhat unwashed things I
mean like in code base64 does that even
make any sense anymore it's probably the
thing that base and code Falls or or
it's probably some variant thereof right
now you know find divisions I thought we
actually had that don't we have a find
divisions in maybe we don't that would
be a nice thing to have in somewhere
available you know you know that's the
thing that finds nicer tick marks and
things find divisions is in system so
why is it in here as well for backward
compatibility oh I see right so for
example if we wanted to say that you
know to Packer a and from Packer a and
Pachter a queue I mean I don't think we
should actually do anything with packed
array form and I think we should
actually deed document and hide that
thing
right okay yeah go ahead
then what but but you know if you want
to declare that you know we should make
to Petri and from Petri impact or EQ you
know system functions I would have no
objection to that of course we would
keep the developer context sure guy
there for backward compatibility let's
talk about I I think this is the wrong
moment to pro these two system because
you know we've got the compiler and it's
hole type system coming up and I think
we might have a more general version of
this right that is does things I mean
you know there may be other sort of
custom types like this right and we're
working right and I mean I mean this is
ongoing discussion with numeric array so
I mean yeah you know that's not an
unreasonable argument but I think like I
said I think turning the documented ones
which you know direct hit into function
repository is just creating confusion I
mean the first question right the reason
this even became an issue on my radar is
people started asking well what's the
difference between the two Factory and
developer and the two peccary in the
function repository okay let's review
what we have here okay
okay somebody needs to go through this
list and figure out what the story is
like partition map by the way could we
please try to arrange that this thing is
not off you know that the base line
isn't yeah yes this has been I've
reported this like eight times okay by
the way
I think we should say in what in these
in these obsolescence messages we should
say 10.2 paren 2014 or whenever it was
okay um okay so question is what the
story with these developer backtick
things actually is so statutory was
we'll go through the documentation
documented symbols first for all the
standard packages because the it is easy
for us to evaluate them so that is what
we did and once we finish them then
we'll go to the ones which are
undocumented okay so yeah you have not
okay fine all right so I think that the
conclusion here is
temporarily call off the the attempt to
make 2-pack array from pact or ABB
function repository things let's
reassess this okay just those two
symbols well is there anything else that
was being promoted was being put from
developer into a function repository ten
what are they
poly lab simplify cell information Zita
simplify factory q polygamous simplified
missile simplify machine into JQ gamma
simplify I have to say I don't know
check to any of those I think the front
pack to write to Packer a lot more
special I think they're more used ok a
toy do you agree right I mean I think
the Packer array ones in particular
should not be there because they're
they're widely known and used the the
simplify errs I think nobody I mean I'm
not sure anybody still uses them because
you know we've made reduce and simplify
so much better I don't I can ask Adam if
there's any use for these I mean I
forgot that there were so many simplify
ones and right in like trig two radicals
right that functionality is now when I
forget which which one it is right but
it's well if you listen if it's really
been superseded then we shouldn't even
put it in the function repository okay
that should be determined okay okay um
fine
all right let me just see just for for
for interest experimental what the what
the status of that is
okay this
tons of stuff here that doesn't make any
sense because cylindrical gerbic
decomposition we have that gray code
well we certainly have that I didn't
even know there was an experimental gray
code thing I think that was I think that
was that I think that was the final fate
of the thing we almost created but then
there were too many issues so we okay
but now there's a function repository
version yeah I will check if that's the
experimental if it's taken from the
experimental context but I think that is
what it is okay
so there are things here I don't know
what any of these are Jarrow distance I
thought we had a thing like that okay
well so have you
you should go through the okay so listen
one possibility what is angle range
anybody have any idea what that is that
sounds like a Brett function nope and
it's not one of the six experimental
context functions that has documentation
yeah and the only one which we have in
function repository apart from gray code
is value function from those yeah so I
really think I mean like tabulate is a
good function I could do all this typing
in our ear not do that please okay
so could you get the function repository
team to look at these please yep go
Fantine instance seems promising as well
look when we think there's something
here that is just really dead like it's
completely superseded I don't know what
we should do we could put a
documentation stub that just says it's
superseded do we think we can remove
anything and experimental so I think
yeah there's some good stuff here
there's some definitely some stuff that
can be used in function depository
alright well we'll let's let's do that
first and then we'll go from that yep
okay
all right male liked to misuse oh boy is
this horrifying yes basically all right
so yeah so I delved into male item and I
and friends and okay so the first issue
is attachments so you can go to well I
guess we now have this replicated in
several places but you know I think it's
on mail item and we have like four or
five different none of which is actually
the one I would actually want which is
one issue in at the present time hold on
hold on hold on mail item okay so what
are you complaining about you're
complaining about attachments and
attachment data is that correct no I'm
not complaining about attachments in
particular and attachment data and
attachment names and attachment
summaries and attachment associations do
we have Fahim here to defend this I'm
here but this is Shawn's
this is Shawn's territory do we have
shown here to the four yes
yep um right so first item attachment
says list of processed attachments as
expressions but if you actually look at
this then you get a list of rules which
seems I mean if I'm importing these
things as expressions what do I care
what their file name was okay Sean can
you talk about these things but first of
all is that other examples somewhere
there are examples
unlike the if you look at like you know
yeah on that page then you will see
examples there so the documentation
started in male receiver function and we
copied the documentation over fern bar
you broke up hello anybody there
Roxy what can you show on showing you
your your I don't know where you are but
but you're you broke up there we
couldn't hear you can you I can't if
you're saying something we can't hear it
where are you Minnesota Minnesota okay
well they have internet in Minnesota
last I knew um alright so I can I can
tell you so my understanding of the
story is that it was first created for
male receiver function and then it was
copied into e ml and M box and since
mail item since the mail folder or
whatever the name of you know male mail
item is a wrapper around
EML right so right so if you open import
n elements and then attachments elements
okay that doesn't seem stupid okay III
agree
my argue is to God but that that's a
little weird right then there's
attachment names which is stupid it's a
little bit I mean I don't know
completely why you would have it but it
could be useful right I am so sorry can
you hear me now yes okay my internet
completely died that is uncommon okay um
all right attachment data we don't Wow
yeah I think I'm right I put in right so
I put it that is not a very useful
example if I might say so if you do
something right if you look in my in
India gender there I have just the keys
or maybe I yeah so you can this seems a
little crazy I admit this does seem a
little crazy
alright so let's go let's my god okay
there okay so let's look back here
attachment names I don't have a problem
with rate doesn't seem attachment
summaries I also don't have a problem
well but what's a little weird here is
that
attachment data and attachment
associations overlap except for content
right but you know arguably to what
extent should we think about this should
this have been named arrow and then the
summary you see what I'm saying and to
what extent is it right to have it be
this triple like that I just don't know
how attachments what what can
attachments be are they always named or
not
but they can be inline are they always
named Jenny do you know this one I don't
think so I don't think so if it's in my
attachment we don't have names can you
not type in our earth who I was doing
that please um okay so what would happen
if there was an inline attachment and
you asked for attachment names missing
okay so what would it do here if there
was an unnamed attachment missing for
the left hand side that's crazy i
unmuted just so you could hear well it
gets pretty crazy especially the missing
on the right hand side also has so if
that's also missing it just becomes a
huge mess all right what do we know in
terms of backward compatibility if we
changed I think what we should do is
deprecated attachments call that
attachment list and have it be simply a
list of the right-hand sides
yep makes sense for backward
compatibility we should continue to have
attachments here but but that you could
extract but we will not
okay so then attachment names is okay um
attachment summaries seems okay now
let's talk about the other ones here
what the heck is this so attachment data
is raw data which seems worth having
I mean it's slightly duplicated but I
think that that is that's worth having
now the final one that you have
attachment what were you calling the
final one associations is attachment
data plus one key which is content
content that doesn't seem worth having I
recommend we do document that because I
think that's duplicate if I'm in other
words you either okay one thing right so
the one thing we don't have here
is
what if you have attachments where
[Music]
hold on the the case that I'm thinking
about is the case where you want to do
something based on the name of the
attachment but you actually want the
expression version of the attachment to
go and I'm saying how would you get that
rather than having to do a re-import on
the raw content
see what I'm saying sorry I'm not sure I
follow
okay so let's say we've got attachments
labeled ABC right and what I want to do
is I want to operate on the expressions
that are attachments ABC knowing the
names ABC how do I do that
what we're proposing to do here
that's a good question well so one thing
you could do is index into attachment
names right I mean if you did in them if
you did a map thread on attachment names
and attachment list can't adjust your
association map if it's an association
yes but but it isn't an association
where's the association with Toki of
getting rid of attachment associations
okay why do we want raw content is it a
fallback in case we can't import it
right then you can import the bait
string with them query string however
you want or if you want
I mean deer so I personally don't think
I would ever want it but I can conceive
of if you want to write directly you
know access the data and do whatever you
know manipulate it yourself because I
know you want to save it and sign it
separately or something but wait wait a
second what is the story with digital
signatures and things like that do we
know how that relates to all of this
that's not really done what even by gun
so as in I don't I well I'm I'm you sort
of have to manual if you want to verify
a signature you need to sort of manually
download you know import things and
verify the signature we don't have on
either you know read mail item or
whatever the name of the function is and
or on send mail okay I understand I
understand but we've got now the digital
signature functionality so the question
is how will that weave into this okay
that's a question once you already have
the data or is that just first send mail
IMAP stuff what's up again is that going
to be relevant for email and M box where
you already have the data or is that
just on so no IMAP instead I don't know
it certainly I mean it isn't principle
readable because if you
if the if it's signed with a key known
by something then your mail client can
tell you whether the thing is correctly
signed or not I mean mod is all whenever
somebody sends me an email that that's
that has a signature attached you know
mutt has will you tell me I don't know
this key aren't these just a part of the
received headers like the is that what
you're talking about guys why don't you
go figure this out we're not sure okay
okay so the question really is this
thing with attachments got nutty because
of the fact that it has repeated keys it
would have been fine if it had been an
association but it can't be because the
repeated keys associate with missings
right
that correct okay well not just missings
you can send the same attachment name
twice in an email right how many other
import formats do we have where we have
the same issue the home repeat things
that should be associations but they
have repeated keys can we can we that's
a question for shadi and other people
can we investigate that yep okay um um
could you please not type in our ear
could you just set it up so that that
isn't how it works um okay
well what I mean I think attachment list
is a reasonable thing to do that we
would add to these functions
and again
um
yeah Carl a live stream is asking why
don't we generate unique names for
nameless or duplicated attachments
because that's even gonna be even more
confusing I think if the duplicated name
I mean I don't even know what it would
mean you know when we have a duplicated
name there yeah right we wouldn't be
importing the right data
okay so back to the question of what
whether one cares about associating the
name of the attachment see I could
imagine something okay I don't just
don't know how people use mail
attachments enough I mean I could could
you imagine a thing where it's always
the attachment called you know fish that
is the relevant thing
how do people manage mail attachments
how do they deal with the I why don't
with on this call by no chance no let's
ask him
we I need to find somebody who knows
about how mail you know what the typical
conventions are for mail attachments
which I do not know but provisionally I
think we should have attachment list we
should deprecated attachments I think we
should deprecated attachment
associations and just have attachment
data okay that's my suggestion but I
would like to check that I would like
you guys to go figure out about digital
signature things and I'd like to check
with somebody who is more familiar with
what actually goes through mail servers
sound reasonable yes okay only one of
several issues oh it's the next wrist
you all right so so close it close it
close this thread because this thread
was about the element you know so open
it well the the yeah that subsection
right so we did the first two yeah so my
third sorry I have one that's slightly
more related okay documentation here
with like these attachments elements one
things that has always confused me is
the description doesn't necessarily tell
you exactly which keys are in you know
for example attachment data we have the
same problem with something like message
summary message elements full message
elements we give a vague description on
the right hand side on the table above
and import elements but without actually
calling keys you don't know exactly what
this is and I find that you say we
should say it these should we document
that
I think it should be a note right here
okay in line we should say in line
something like attachment data consists
of a live you know attachment data
contains associations with keys blehh
blehh blehh blehh blehh the names of the
keys okay and do we want so do we right
so we duplicate one but not both of
those keys in the table in the table
three notes down with with the
attachment related elements so I think
we should either repeat all of them or
none of them look why don't we put the
notes at the very end then let's put the
notes at the end here okay but I think
he's saying that Association shows up in
two of these tables if you scroll up
it's in the very first attachment
element and then it's also listed under
attachment related elements III know so
okay so fine so I'm saying put the note
at the very end of the whole thing down
right but my question is is we have an
inconsistent here that we have
attachments and attachments data in the
basic element I'm aware I know well I
don't think there's a problem in
repeating that because I that's Steven
let me finish my sentence please okay go
ahead so we have an inconsistency in
that we repeat attachments in that is
more specialized table but we don't
repeat attachments data so is the error
that we repeat attachments or is it the
error that attachments data should be in
that bottom table
the error is that attachment data should
be in the bottom table okay
okay and I would argue that in this
basic elements thing we should actually
leave attachment data out as it happens
and we should just have attachment list
okay all right next item down here
why does mail item mail search returned
a data set and not a bunch of okay so
that relates to the same question as why
text search what text search returns
what web search returns and so on
they've all got to be consistent and
that's a and they're not right now okay
so that was a separate thing I think
Sushma we were talking about that yeah
so all of those returns data set now
except for text search because text
search is a different thing because we
don't have a lazy data set concept right
now but there are web web image search
and other things it isn't data set okay
well and so I mean maybe this is just an
implementation the detail that needs to
be solved but for example if you you
know do mail search to search for
something and then you try to extract
the attachment then you get missing of
not available or right so here's the
problem with that we don't actually
import attachments when we are doing a
mail search because you can get the
whole mailbox in memory so to be
somewhat quick and be reasonable
we don't actually import attachments
when you do a mail search if you want
you potentially just have to get the
mail item by doing the indexing of mail
folder like mail folder one or two no I
mean sure whatever we return in the
results of mail sir
should have a handle from which you can
get the mail item with all of its
attachments why doesn't it okay so you
want me to extract the data say it said
has mail items in it which is just a
preview it's not actually full light no
I understand well you two want to get
the attachment for that mail item how
would you do it you can do that yes you
just excuse me
you just get to hold my light and you
just get the position and get the mail
light even if I made the current
workflow is you take the item you want
you extract the key I believe its key or
maybe position this you extract the
position which is currently returned on
as a string so you have to call to
expression on it to turn it into an
integer right on little Alfred start
however I will fix that yes okay and
then do mail folder of that key to get
the full item why I don't stand if you
just extract the mail item blob mm-hmm
okay why isn't mail item a summary box
well it probably should be and and if it
became a summary box hidden inside that
summary box could be the handle
information that would allow you to
index into mail item and say mail item
of attachment list for example and then
just retrieve the attachment list
magically so to speak because the
attachment list would not be present in
that raw mail item summary box it can be
done yes right yeah I think what we need
is mail item property extraction to be
smarter so if you do mail item of right
see it gets slightly more complicated if
you are thinking about mail item a
random key from the documentation of EML
right then you do it you just go back
and retrieve the mail item I mean what's
what's wrong with that and
any case what will happen as you
download the whole mail item and then do
an input on it you you can't really do
from directly from the server one of
these keys so it's fine it's it's
totally fine we can do that okay all
right yeah well I mean we can discuss on
offline if needed but I think basically
all we need is mail item if it sees oh I
don't have an attachment and you regret
yes yeah go get it right yeah okay we
got a couple of comments from the
livestream interesting and Genesis asks
why not have one key with a list of
values because that way if we do that
it's it's unpredictable what you'd end
up with and you'd end up having to
encrust even Singleton's and lists ethan
asks primary reason why I can't use
attachments is that images get resized
arbitrarily into low res versions for
heme as Sean or anybody else can you
comment on that is that in the front end
because that's just the default behavior
if so that's I suspect the default
behavior of the front end that you can
get around by just right-clicking and
selecting original size that's what I
would expect we just do a default import
so it should preserve the quality we
don't do anything more than the we get
all the original data okay fair enough
so what you're saying is just that the
image whatever it is is being is looking
smaller but it is in fact all the pixels
are there so what you're saying so I
mean if I for example did something like
you know if I just take a random screen
capture here Blunk like that and put it
in here
great we still have that bug we still
have that bug I still had to Reese
switch more I think this is for you to
report again again again again I thought
trying to fix that bug the bug that that
required this to get refocused in order
to have be a target for the screen
capture thing anyway so this might look
like it's low res but it's actually not
low
right right and if you put braces around
it or something right if you select
automatic size where is actual size okay
there we go
no it's crisp okay um just a second
right and my point is with automatic
size it might how big it looks might
depend on like whether it's inside a
list or on its own and things like that
yes right okay Ethan is also asking
saying we need the ability to search the
contents of attachments for him your
comments you you'll have to do a text
search on it you can't do it live mail
search is an IMAP search it's it's not a
search on random stuff you can do okay
so let's walk through that for a second
for example my mail search huh right
from whenever it is 20 something years
ago it's being updated now to use text
search right it is I don't even know how
it works I mean it has I don't know what
the attachments look like that does
anybody know all that what is stored in
my in my mail archive is its is it EML
files or what it should be base64 all
the attachments yes you have email files
and those contain usually base64 okay
and text search is doing what with those
EML files are we as as the index is
created in text search are we are we
cracking the ml we're cracking open the
base64 and the email file to feed things
into the search index is that correct
right well one thing that we're working
on right now is basically being able to
find an adequate plaintext
representation like by format and
specify that to MLM box to solve this
problem so wait a minute walk me through
that again so so you're saying that what
one of the things that we might want in
the future is textual you know is
something that's called attachment text
or something well something like yes
would be very useful but all
a more general form of this where you
can specify specific import elements by
type and that could be either by mime
type or format specification or whatever
okay the bottom line if I've got a
picture of a squid or something and it's
just an image in the current state of
the world I mean we could run image
identify and discover that it's a
picture of a squid that would be one
approach that's probably gonna be pretty
slow sure but but right right because
what's in your EML file is write the
base64 encoding of it so unless we I
understand we know we're gonna have to
crack open the base64 I'm going to do
text search anyway right so I mean
that's just a judgment call we can pick
what elements we want meaning we could
pick some kind of metadata to search
through well we could do the excerpts of
the images but the exif you know knowing
that was taken on a nikon camera or
something is not the most exciting thing
usually no we haven't really decided
what the best form for images would be
in a text search maybe the file name is
the most useful thing at that point
filename is the only useful thing other
than a natural image identify which I
don't think is crazy to run we have that
technology it doesn't it's not that slow
takes 50 milliseconds or something to
run one of those doesn't seem crazy to
me and it's better sounds like per
stressing to me well it's part of look
we know that in text search the first
stage of text search is what do we
actually put in the index right and so
that we expect a bunch of options in
what we put in the index this is
something again has to be coordinated
with Nick um
Nicholas look my yeah um and who is by
the way now moving to the machine
learning group so that's where that
further development is going to be
merged with the NLP stuff there um I
just want to make sure that if the user
Ethan is asking that if mail search
should do the search or should it be
imported first and then you do the
search because the workflow would be
simpler if mail search runs all that
stuff yes but as you point out that's
basically impossible to run it on the
IMAP server mail service is running
using the IMAP
call and just can't do it yes um I mean
the alternative what is the alternative
I mean for somebody in Rio caso in my
own case for example the way it's done
is that I have a plain file system of
all of my mail right does anybody here
know I mean that's my system is also I
mean I can drill down the file system to
an attached notebook yes yeah well I I
think that's how mine works so the
question really is okay so when people
search I don't know when in the in the
in the you know cloud email providers
surely they let you search on
attachments don't pay well that actually
depends on client I'm pretty sure Gmail
will actually go into some text
attachments but that's the only one that
I saw like Thunderbird Apple Mail etc
it's just file names yeah that's so
primitive well I mean so is there a way
for mail search to search you know the
local copy of your mail that's another
problem with mail search now people
confuse it with a normal mail client but
it's not you see we never save a EML
file on disk no no I mean I have your
whole bunch of inboxes right locally to
my file system yeah so that isn't that
isn't using you know webmail basically
right right now mail search okay so hold
on so one possibility would be that one
could row for example I have no idea
does the max spotlight search does it
run on the local copy of the mbox yes
I'm sure it does I use it all the time
okay so in principle our text search
could be running on the local copy of
the mbox file including attachments
as opposed to running on the live IMAP
server I think that should be
investigated I don't see why we wouldn't
want to have that be a option I mean
what's the advantage of running on the
remote IMAP server that's because it's
not local that's the advantage I don't
think spotlight is looking through like
an M box file I think the way that
certain clients store all this stuff on
your computer is different it's not a
hundred percent sure I mean I do know
that in a lot of these cases there is
somewhere sitting on my file system the
actual attachment yeah yeah right okay
listen this is a Chris Smith question
why don't we ask these questions and try
and unscramble this but it does seem to
me like it's not completely crazy to
imagine something at least in the future
where we could do you know where mail
search there could be a version of mail
search that's effectively doing a local
search using text search on your local
copy of your inbox
Fred we're definitely going to what
we're doing right now is mostly taking M
boxes and then creating an index that
you can use text search on so you know I
understand all right okay and so I think
that's what you're getting at though
right I mean so it's right so they're
right there
storage storage formats are independent
of the IMAP protocol right so the the
how the mail server chooses to cache
thing locally it can do it as an as as a
mail der as an M box you know as email
it can even use MH format if it's really
really bold and retro and I think one of
the things about Zimbra is that right it
they're using their own custom back-end
which is why they're you know for for
both better and for worse you know they
have done custom back-end but they
expose things using the IMAP protocol so
any client can read that
then cache it locally however at once
right I mean the factors call on our
life's treatment saying he doesn't think
he's ever needed attachment such well
the thing is I for example and many of
us probably have many many notebooks as
attachments it better they better get
searched
um and I'm pretty sure at least mine do
I certain here they must do they must do
because I've had like reports of various
kinds that I would never have found
unless yeah okay
so actually this is the thing Sushma
could you check with Raja about how
that's working for my mail okay right so
if I mean if you're if you're if you're
using Apple Mail then I'm almost certain
right Apple Mail I'm not using I'm not
using it for my search system I have my
own custom search system built 20 years
ago and rebuilt recently using text
search I see okay all right let's try
and do a few more items from this agenda
please um if we I think we're there's
more investigation that has to be done
on this whole you know searching
searching attachments the relationship
to text search and so on so this was
pretty I think we just wanted a to
actually make sure we wanted we actually
knew what the design was before we
implemented something common occurrences
of expressions matching a pattern all
levels just like count okay I may
and that I said I was wrong that sounds
pretty normal okay all right fair enough
um okay okay what is the what is the
pattern argument will so count it's just
counting the number of things of that
pattern right right okay
count distinct why on earth is it not
referred to here is there a count
distinct at one distinct anyone others
isn't it referred to in count assumably
because they didn't bother to edit
well let's looked at it um hold on let's
put it I would argue that that um it
should be this is a crazy ordering here
I mean both sequence count
string count seemed highly relevant to
count much more relevant than some of
these just seem great okay why wait so I
mean this is it's not completely crazy
because count is something that works
with the pattern matcher and so they so
certainly before any of these and it's a
much older function right before those
so I think people either just added them
at the end already decided to keep the
pattern matching related ones together
that they may have been wrong but I
think all wrong I think I think that
those I'm gonna fix it here I'm just
waiting for the update to finish it so
that I can make sure I'm updating the
correct version um how can this still be
ref pages that are getting put into the
I know I'm curious there's a thing
called Ripley K what an earth is that
how could I have not heard of this
whatever it is it's a statistical
distribution and it's probably still
future eyes ah it's special I can't tell
you exactly what it is but they know
probably spatial statistics and these
are probably future eyes pages and
that's why I'm not not seeing them and
but they're getting put in there build
okay no prob I mean they're getting put
in there in the system but not on the
build alright it's all good um okay have
me worried there okay so now let's look
at count
okay I claim this is really pretty crazy
this list I agree that cases is useful
there
well that family is okay but leaf count
I mean freak you and member kew makes
sense to me this is a bit embarrassing
okay so I claim count distinct probably
actually is the very first thing is
their account by function I think so or
maybe not
maybe one doesn't need it no it doesn't
need a count distinct buy one needs I
claimed sequence counters the next one
its counts by okay I think leaf count is
just barely relevant there's a mess
why is match queue relevant remember
queue because because the pattern has to
match right yeah I understand but count
is it's only faintly relevant okay so
counts by no counts by
a different thing that's collected two
counts right which I claim should also
be much more prominent slight bin counts
counts that's alright that's okay that's
alright what's that okay
seems to me we better check some other
functions around this um some of these
may be really really really antediluvian
so to speak
actually that looks much more reasonable
alright I think we just had anomaly here
okay in any case all right so count
distinct so we've got count which has a
pattern of level spec and now we've got
count distinct why the heck doesn't have
a pattern level spec oh I see I see
count distinct is simply counting okay
I'm I'm sorry I'm a little confused here
what I did with count wasn't quite right
unless we add
I'm so confused here okay what I did
there wasn't right because the count
distinct is not the most relevant thing
okay I think leaf count is really
irrelevant why is leaf count even
vaguely relevant
and nobody see any reason why that's
relevant no I don't think so
I think count distinct actually is more
related to counts because count distinct
default Li is the number of
things so I mean it's length of delete
duplicates right yes okay but but so
what you're saying is we might want to
prune the count distinct by a pattern or
by a level spec right right so so the
original suggestion was yes we might
want to limit to a pattern and we might
want to level spec but if it's count
distinct then maybe same test is so the
question is right do do we need a
pattern or doing you the same test or do
we need both it's really the question Oh
same test will be nice but a pattern is
saying what do you even care about it
all right
no I mean so in other words what I might
want is something like you know count
distinct you know in this list
everything of the form F of blank great
I mean you know arguably I could just
say cases list a for blank and then do
count distinct on that right well I mean
count distinct is clearly a tally
function and so for all we know the
implement implementation is length of
delete duplicates I love the way that
it's called
you know that tally didn't did did tally
invent the function tally
anybody remember no he replaced the
function tally because tally didn't like
tally right right that's why counts
exists right
but either way yeah I mean counts versus
tally is a college commenting I know
that's not a favorite thing um why does
counts
why doesn't counts have a same test well
partly because the counts has to have a
left-hand side to its to its some
associations and how would you pick the
representative right I mean it would
have to have an arbitrary choice it
would say it's the first one that is in
the same test equivalence class exactly
but you're right that that makes it
harder to use right um which is why by
words right okay so here okay count
distinct I agree that the same test
seems to make decent sense of what
counts as distinct so to speak but now
the question is is it worth having a
pattern
I don't like the idea of mixing those
two things I think these are two
different families but the same test
family is like tally gather split and
then use buttons no I understand but
this is using a pattern for a different
purpose this is a pattern for pruning
purposes oh I see what you say tally
could perfectly well tally things
according to you know pruned by a
pattern but it doesn't right I think
it's a balance it already prune syncs
fine so we're the cases basically right
and arguably there should be an example
showing that in the count distinct
documentation um so we should put that
in there but but um okay but so now what
about a level spec
that seems fine yeah but the problem is
with argument ordering that's hard to
have a level spec without having you
know then we're having a level spec
without having a pattern and that's kind
of confusing well if we do have a
pattern into the like level it's like
level and then the leader precast soft
level what do you mean sorry I'm oh I
see level the function yes right I see
where your point is that count distinct
of level could just give the thing on
that level right all the elements aren't
on that level
and then get the distinct ones okay so
the only part that is not so I mean
that's arguing for a same test because
that's not replicable by something else
it's arguing that we simply document
using cases and level which is what
they're for so to speak to get to that
that point that sounds sensible to me
that we have a same test and we just
document the cases in level thing yeah
and I was just going to point out that
with you know if the if if we use tally
as our modeled and that you know it has
rather than same tested well it has an
optional second argument and it doesn't
have a list it doesn't have a level spec
or anything right and it has a second
argument that is its same test basically
right right which is what delete
duplicates does also which which is how
count distinct as implemented
well that makes a lot of sense to me
all right so then then that would be a
second argument for count distinct
mm-hmm
fine it's in that family let's do it um
and then we should document the way of
using level and cases here okay makes
sense okay we're running out of time
here
yeah this one that I don't think is
quite so simple yeah so go ahead just um
um let me just remember to push this
back this public eight I just did back
um Oh what is this what is this
partition should work on associations
right which is not this is a suggestion
and I don't know that I agree and even
if I do agree it's not obvious like what
it should return cuz right partition
doesn't take arbitrary heads and you
know well what you're trying to do here
is to take the association treated as a
list of elements in sequence and
partition those right why you want to do
this I haven't a clue but I mean well
for example if you if you're trying to
paginate something or something like
that you might want to do that it's the
hour log of take right if I if I just do
take on that Association if I'm not
mistaken um
yeah that does the right thing so the
issue is I think the problem is that
take preserves the head but partition
needs to introduce a new head which is
usually the same one it had and it
cannot be with Association yeah as as
Sandra is pointing out on the live
stream
you know partition is perfectly happy to
take an arbitrary head right yes I did
there is weird weird that it puts that f
as the outer head that's really weird
well maybe it is I don't know yeah I
mean I don't ah yes I misspoke earlier
when I said it doesn't take right and
the problem is with an association you
won't be able to use the same head you'd
have to use a list as the outer head
right I think there's also a question of
what you would do for padding which is
another case where you'd have to sort of
introduce keys
it also be a list of a socks well that's
right but the issue that's being pointed
out is when there's padding how do I
introduce padding here up to four I'm
sorry that's the non padded case
yeah that's non-pilot right well that's
pretty weird so what just happened I bet
we didn't think of that case huh yeah
that's wrong absolutely that's just a
bug
um but it sort of demonstrates the point
yeah what you do with the additional
elements when they're going to be
padding elements which those were not
supposed to be but they're there
yeah I mean you need a default key it's
like having a sparse Association which
we don't have that notion right well
that's right you can't repeat keys so
you
you're right this is a more complicated
topic another time that would be useful
that would be useful we should talk
about a little bit more that that would
be useful yeah I don't entirely
understand what Constantine is asking
for he's on pto that which is why I
moved it to the bottom so okay fine just
wait wait what is all screaming sorry
there's already an import export file
format queue it's just whether or not we
want to promote it to system right I
mean what this is doing is it seems
quite sensible to me it's simply a test
that you would put you know if not you
know your file , give then error out but
I think the more interesting case then
we should note this for when we talk
about this is is this an image file
right that's the more interesting type
of thing to ask is it a work file an
image file ah you know were we to read
this in would it turn into an image or
will it turn into a you know a potato
chip or something yeah that makes sense
we need some well it matters whether
it's a JPEG or a gif or whatever else
that's not the important thing
yeah I mean I think we need some notion
of lake format groups yeah right ray
that would also be useful I still think
it would be fine to bump this in the
system for an actual test for a specific
format so that you can test it before
calling import fine but let's discuss
this along with the image groups thing
at another time okay I think we're
wrapping up here those who are following
the live stream we will be doing another
live stream at the top of the hour
um about incremental language
development and some of the same people
will be there isn't it at 4:00 I said at
the top of the hour which is always
known as I mean it's 3 p.m. Central Time
oh okay that's why I was confused so
that's why it's the top of the hour
because um okay see you guys soon okay
thanks bye